this episode is a tiny bit longer than I
kind of wanted it to be since you know I
had a little time lapse of me doing the
things that I had kind of planned but
then I also started working in the
station for the log flume and that just
added 50 and added five minutes whoops -
the video is so ticularly a tiny bit
long now I try to go for somewhere
between 10 and 15 minutes but it's
slightly over 15 minutes not really a
huge deal but anyway in this episode I
was going to work on the log flume like
I said and a tiny bit of the station and
also tiny bit of path work sorry and
removing this building which by the way
I've got some people say that you know
it looks more arabian in a way than it
looks spanish which i think it's the
interesting thing about the Spanish
architecture is that it's got many
influences of the arabian culture in
there it's kind of like a mishmash
between the mediterranean well it's
probably mostly the mediterranean
classical architecture but there's a
there's a tiny bit of arabian in there
since like i don't know exactly when
don't want to turn this into in a
history history lesson but at some point
in time doing like the 1400 something
the muslims still occupied but the
muslims i'm sorry the what were they
called even it was some muslim people
occupied spain and that just kind of
happened and that's how you got those
influences in there don't really know
for sure actually right now that i'm
doing all this stuff whether i can
actually get the italian or even the
greek theme in the park somewhere since
it'll be really hard to actually cram
that in there and make it look good
since on the other side of the river i
already want and kind of need to start
doing the northern european thing
because otherwise i've there is no room
left to do anything else anymore but
hopefully there is actually some space
where i can add some italian things and
things like that i don't know it also
kind of depends on whether i feel like
to nut or not in any case this building
is actually mostly based on some what's
famous buildings in spain which is
actually also something that black i've
taught me to do probably is to just look
at some famous buildings and just kind
of take your inspiration from that's to
make it looks to make it look like a
certain country which is most likely
going to be the most important thing for
the spanish theme because it isn't like
a Asian theme for example it is really
easy to distinguish a Japanese theme
from like an Indian theme or something
like that since there are completely
different architectural styles but try
to distinguish a Spanish theme for from
an Italian theme to somebody who isn't
really too you know into that type of
architecture it doesn't really know too
much about either type architecture is
kind of hard so you kind of need to go
into the signature buildings and styles
so that's why the building on the corner
over there is kind of loosely based on
the metropolis building in Madrid this
little building was based on a picture I
found of something I don't even know the
name of and the station is going to be
inspired by the city hall of Madrid and
so that's kind of how that happened
also there is the superest spam of
course which kind of helps as well
having that you know having that foliage
in there to help us well which by the
way something that many people actually
worried about is having the exact right
foliage climates each thing going on and
it's in their parks which is I mean I
know I just released that foliage
tutorial but you don't really have to
worry about what type of climates a tree
is supposed to be in as long as you
don't place too many of them if you
place them for example on a path like
you can place palm trees in any northern
European country safely but make sure
that it's like close to the paths and
stuff and that it's in a planter that it
can be moved to shelter in the winter
and that it can be maintained correctly
and if you kind of do that then you can
pretty much use any type of foliage that
you really want to by the way I was so
confused
when this terraforming thing happened
because as you can see I tried to play
some different textures in there and
like every single damn [ __ ] square
was like uneven and there were edges and
it was confusing especially since I
don't see any edges and I have no idea
where that actually comes from it's just
kind of an annoying little thing also
yeah there was some stupid
experimentation right there I'm very
sorry about that this was in the middle
of a stream and sometimes in a stream
you just feel like I'm doing some funny
stuff now my blurr song just ended and
it doesn't automatically
go to the next one what are we doing you
can't do that to click it mainly they
would go back and oh yeah right
this planter by the way is I don't know
what but somebody said in the stream
that this thing looked like a banana and
no idea why like it doesn't even look
like one but then when I look at it
closer it still doesn't look like
anything no idea it's just a tiny
planter that I wanted to have those
since there was no other way of actually
getting rid of those little gaps in the
ground unless I wanted to make the paths
wider but that is definitely something
that I didn't want to do and there
weren't any other curves really so this
is about the only solution I could come
up with though I think it looks alright
but in terms of path works and all that
those details I'm still very very unsure
what I'm going to do with this area and
I might actually not plan it and just
wing it seriously since I don't know how
much I'm looking forward to actually
planning this stuff here and I feel like
as long as I keep this like a normal
path area and add some other paths on
the other side leave some room for the
queue and the exit then it should be
fine and this side with having that
weird stone and grass in the middle and
weird shapes is going to be kind of like
having planters over there and also
tables and chairs for restaurants so
that should all be alright by the way I
need to thank Vicky once again because
she literally saved my life I never
really knew that okay here's an issue
yeah I need to address that first the
issue is that I've always wondered and
complained about this jello water since
you know I have some pretty high
graphics settings and all the codes that
go through you don't get yellow water
the water is reflective it is deep blue
it is beautiful and it's actually really
good and it's better than what we've
seen in like some of the games like the
screens from RCT world and [ __ ] which is
pretty cool for in the 2004 game but
still you know when you when you I
placed some water elsewhere it would
turn into jello water for some reason
never really knew why but turns out that
if you have like water is a different
Heights within the park you can only
have the reflective beautiful water at
one height so if you place that like
somewhere and then place
what are elsewhere but at a different
elevation then it turns into jell-o
water so yeah I basically learned that I
have to keep all my water at the same
height it's not really too big of an
issue but it kind of restricts you in
what you really want to do and also I
was planning on having some what's
really higher up on the hills on this
log flume but that is not going to
happen in the end since it is really
hard to even make that and I'm not too
big of a fan of the yellow water also
buckle up for how many minutes three or
four more minutes of log flume building
since this was actually taken quite a
while I wanted to have one mountain in
the middle where both the lift hills
would go up on and we're both drops
would be and I wanted to have some room
left for a scenery and things like that
and it wasn't really quite as easy as I
hoped it was it's I kind of want to go
for a choppers it's thing which I know
is that before but I want to have that
big diagonal drop in the middle right
there where I can add buildings and
rocks around it at least that's kind of
how I have it planned right now and then
I kind of wanted to tuck the lift Hills
on the edge of the mountain so you don't
really see them too much but it was
really hard to actually connect those
things so yeah this is where the pain
starts and oh my god I think I took two
more minutes to kind of finish that
since you know sometimes you're building
a layout and it just doesn't work and
then as soon as you give up on that just
remove half the layout and decide to do
it in a completely different way that
turns out to work even less well and I
hate it when that happens
seriously so yeah it actually took quite
a bit of work to get this log flume to
actually work but I think it's alright
right now it doesn't really take too
much space and you know I do have some
nice little thing up there I can add
scenery around it and where the highest
drop is actually also going to be the
highest point of the mountain so I feel
pretty safe about that honestly the only
thing that you know is obviously a tiny
bit strange about this thing is that you
it doesn't even have log flume areas on
top of that mountain it's almost like a
aqua coaster but I think that should be
alright hell maybe if I'm not lazy but
that is probably not going to happen
I could make some scenery food on it but
that's just I don't even know how to do
that exactly I don't even wish this
towards making scenery for track pieces
plus I I'm too late if you thought like
I said just don't do that so yeah this
is something that I tried at first and I
figured you know I could have a small
little river over there at the end of
both lift hills but although that would
be cool it just takes so much more space
and it's really not efficient and
efficient and then the train would have
to go around that and that would be kind
of painful so I had to change that in
the end but we're almost there I think
yeah this is almost at the point where I
decided to no [ __ ] it I'm just going to
move that thing I finally decide to get
a brain and just make a simple curve and
then it should work in the end I think
that's just kind of how that works out
yeah there we go
simple curve and it it matches up and
it's all perfect and at that point I
figured alright that's going to be this
episode thank you for watching and I'll
see you guys in the next episode but
that didn't exactly happen as it just
keeps going oh my god that is that is
not good like if they's out because I
figured that was going to be the episode
but then I made a tiny time-lapse this
morning because I still had some time
and yeah that's how we got over here and
it's time to build this palace which
looking back at it I mean you haven't
really seen anything of its but I feel
like it's going to turn into a nice
little station but I say a little but
it's damn humongous thing is that I'm
kind of worried about its size though
I'm kind of worried about its size kind
of making the mountain seem a tiny bit
smaller but for now I just want to keep
it and see how I can work around it
because I am somewhat happy about how it
turned out in the end especially for
something that I haven't really tried
out before but I think I'll just let the
video speak for how it's going to be I'm
not going to really say anything about
it I realized that I always say that you
know I don't like
my own stuff like I get that yeah it is
pretty annoying when I build things and
I'm like I don't like that mmm-hmm
which is like me in half of my episodes
but yeah sometimes I just feel not so
sure about what I want to build and
whenever I'm like that I'm also kind of
unsure about what comes out of it and
yeah I just kind of I don't know it's I
just kind of would express that as well
since this isn't all about the videos
that I make for the let's play but it's
really also about the park and the park
is the main objective actually and I
want to keep it that way for this series
and something that I haven't really
complained about too openly and I'm
gonna [ __ ] do this is rose gardens the
fact that that is one of my least
favorite things I've ever made at some
point in the middle of rose gardens like
I think the beginning is good and the
ending is good but at some point in the
middle I felt like I had to work on it
for the let's play and it kind of is
visible in the park itself it really
turns generic halfway through I think
and kind of uninspired and that is
something that I want to avoid and I
know I am complaining about something
that I made again and I don't really
wish to do that too much but I think it
was a learning experience for me that I
really wanted to focus on what I am
building rather than the let's play and
I even think that in the end that's
going to make the let's play a lot
better since I just feel like it's you
need to play the game when you wanna
have fun with it and creativity is
something that you can't force so even
though I might get some pretty
inconsistent uploads with this park I'm
very sorry yeah in advance if that turns
out to happen but that's kind of the
reason I just want to do I want to work
on this when I have inspiration for it
when I feel like I have some good ideas
and some good plans for it and other
than that I want to not do anything with
it's like if I don't feel like working
on this I'm not going to do that and
hopefully you can understand that that
is the reason but don't worry in the
meantime I can definitely fill up my
time with other stuff and tutorials and
things speaking of which I need to make
loads more of those I haven't really
that too much lately and I was kind of
planning on doing a lot of those but
yeah that's pretty much life I haven't
really talked about this building yet
yeah most people are probably not too
familiar with the City Hall in Madrid
but it's a really large building with a
lot of vertical accents like seriously
that has towers and pillars all over the
place it's got a huge hexagon shaped
tower in the middle and two smaller
hexagon shaped towers on the sides and I
was going to kind of do it like that
which was evidently why I placed our
tower in there in the first place but
this kind of wanted to remove that since
it turned out way too large for the
station and also for what I will have
around this area and like I said as you
can see right now it is turning into
quite a large block in the middle of
this area which I'm hmm
I'm on the fence about its size since it
is so large and it really wants to have
all the attention
so not really sure if that's going to
work out too well but I want to kind of
wait it out
until I get the buildings around it and
the foliage around it because it's it's
really not that large of a building its
footprints is like about what is it I
think it's like yeah it's it's five by
four basically so it's not even that
large so hopefully it is going to work
out I wouldn't want to remove this
building that would be a pain and also
shame so hopefully I can work it out
somehow but yeah this is how it the
building is going to be psyched that
arch in the middle is going to be filled
up by something I just don't know
exactly what's right now but it's not
going to be completely open like that
that can't be anything over there but
yeah that's this building the facade is
basically finished at this point just
need to finish the backside and that's
going to happen next episode so see you
then